[Music]
this
is star talk sports edition i'm your
host
neil degrasse tyson your personal
astrophysicist
and today sports edition we've titled
what are the odds
and if you're going to start a program
with that question somewhere in there
there's going to have to be a
mathematician
so we'll get to that in just a moment
but first let me introduce
my co-host chuck nice jackie baby hey
neil
what's happening all right now you you
you pay your rent
telling jokes but so why do we have you
on this
um actually if i were good enough if i
were good enough to pay my rent telling
jokes i wouldn't be here
[Laughter]
all right so uh so chuck no we love you
because you bring some levity where it's
sometimes needed
uh but also you're you're a sports
enthusiast on a level that i think is
uncommon
among people who are not otherwise paid
to have that level of knowledge so
yeah good to have you but where we get
our street cred of course is from gary
o'reilly gary
hey neil what's up all right uh you're a
stateside but
you were raised in the uk played
professional soccer there
and loved talking to you about your
injuries and how you recovered from them
we have whole shows on that
um but but you come from the
professional
world and there's some insight there
that you could bring to this
conversation
because what we have found is that
there's
a superstition can manifest itself
in sports and um superstition tends to
show up
when people are not entirely in control
of the outcome
and so how much in control are they not
is this even quantifiable should
managers
study this should players study this and
so
generally when those kind of issues
arise you need a mathematician
and so we found one we found the perfect
mathematician for this
dr matthew ginsberg matthew matt i think
it is if i can call you
welcome to star talk uh thank you and
yes it's matt
it is matt excellent excellent so you
you have a phd
in mathematics they do
that's dangerous you see because people
don't know how important math is to what
they do
and then a mathematician starts walking
up from and comes into the back door
and you say uh oh they're ready to sort
of shake this up
and to tell us where we're miss thinking
they're gonna straighten us out
they're gonna ruin our superstitions
they're going to and so
do you ruin people's days with your
accent what i found
is that is that when you have two people
who are having an argument
and you come in and you just completely
settle it with mathematics you just say
right they always both love you i mean
it's just
it's totally the way to make friends and
and
it's it's perfect okay yeah okay
i actually i i think you're wrong there
matt yeah i think he's lying
yeah i think what happens is they both
kind of go
that guy's a dick
they're both mad at you because they
both look like idiots
as everybody does uh next to
mathematicians so they really
they just want to have the argument they
actually don't really care about
being wrong right or they just care that
they're disagreeing no no the difference
is it comes
here's how it manifests if you settle it
with a solution that
neither of them had previously
considered embraced
then they're both wrong and then then
then that that magnifies your dickatude
[Laughter]
so we should actually we should get my
wife in here because she will tell you
that
she will be delighted at anything that
you guys can do to
to minimize my dickatube
okay not surprising i guess the
conversation is it took so long to get
here we're all ready to
work no but guess what we're already
making plans to bring him back
based on that statement
and who who knew the word dickatude
actually existed
so so let me ask you and by the way this
is
we have a third segment uh where we just
sort of
chew the fat and shoot the can you
stay for that segment because there are
places i want to get into your
professional profile that would be that
would not be part of the sort of what we
know we must get through because we want
to talk about um
what kind of statistics do you do where
did you get your phd where were
i got my phd in astrophysics oh and it's
mathematical astrophysics from roger
penrose oxford oh
okay let me tell my co-authors he just
totally
name dropped there yeah
total name roger who hardly anyone heard
of before a month ago
when he got the nobel prize right
that was like total total name drops
okay
so that's a double name drop because you
got the oxford on the back of it
you got the oxford you got penrose
famous among all astrophysicists
and and this the throwdown
of the of the nobel prize but so anyhow
so then you
then you started decided to slum it and
do pure math before i went to oxford
i was at caltech for a year where my
supervisor was kip thorne who also
went on to win the nobel prize and i
actually think that i get credit
this is me i'm the common link between
these two scientists
so the reason they both won the nobel
prize prizes you know it's interesting
because
tom cruise who probably will never win
an academy award for acting has been in
in movies
where you know five other academy awards
have been given
to the movie to the other actors to the
thing so he could say that he
enabled the acting uh yeah there you go
there it is exactly yeah this is
probably a dick-a-tude movie that's true
yeah i was going to say i'm i'm kind of
siding with your wife here
so what is the what is the knowledge you
bring
to assist sports people what have you
studied
in your math so um
the math really was twister theory and
quantum mechanics and stuff like that
but since then i spent a lot of time
doing ai
and i made i think most of my career
doing artificial intelligence and
statistics and machine learning
and that's what i bring is the knowledge
of
statistics and what you can predict and
what you can't and
how that kind of information can help
people make better decisions as they
play their games
when we talk about predictive analytics
are we really just talking about
different forms of statistics
and the use of statistics we're often
talking about machine learning
and machine learning is really just sort
of statistics right steroids
no wait are steroids allowed in
computing
for sports computing
i'm sorry i'm gonna have to invalidate
this program
i participated a long time ago in the
world computer bridge championship i
wrote a computer program that played
bridge
and i was at the world computer bridge
championship and they actually
drug tested the program
[Music]
took a sample of blood okay i have no
idea
what this means as far as steroids and
so forth but
people there are people worrying about
this issue so wait so
let me ask if you said there's some
things that you can't predict is because
there's insufficient data
to make a lot a reliable prediction or
would you are used
did you mean to imply that there are
some things that can never be predicted
no matter what so
you can't at some level you can't
actually predict anything with certainty
right so so we all think the sun's going
to come up tomorrow but there are a
variety of things that could cause it
not to
no no don't go there no there's nothing
you're saying that like yeah there's a
50 chance the sun is not gonna rhyme if
i'm a betting
person we're good so let's let's not
worry about the philosophical limits of
what
could or could not happen let's just
talk about what
a certain betting person would bet on
how about that
so what i'm trying to say is all you can
ever
do about the outside world is quote odds
right now if you can make bet if
somebody's willing to bet me
that the sun is not going to come
tomorrow i'm going to take that back
will you give me even odd
i'll make that bet because the sun's
coming up tomorrow yeah you know 99.999
and a lot of nines
similarly if i want to predict that you
know babe ruth pointing to a point in
the stands
i'm gonna hit a home run and it's gonna
go there
it's not a hundred percent there's some
chance that he gets to honor that
prediction and the question is
what is how accurately can you gauge the
probabilities and how close can you get
them to one or zero
correct and so a zero is certainty it
won't happen
and a one is certainty it will happen
right okay and so
of course sports there's a lot of
betting in sports
and if you could put a shading of
insight into an outcome you could become
a very wealthy man
yeah but i wouldn't have any fun
okay okay okay uh i let me just
uh put a quick addendum to that matt um
you would with all the money that you
would get
so yes you're right you would not have
any fun in the process
however the results the result you have
after your accuracy
afterwards all right so what about
curses where people have long losing
streaks and they think they're cursed
and this is where superstition comes in
it seems to me mathematicians are highly
needed in those moments
so all we can we can tell you that you
know you're probably not
cursed okay so there's a chance you're
actually cursed
that's what you're saying there's a
chance of anything
right now it's imagine i give you a coin
right and you start tossing it it comes
up heads heads heads heads heads
at some point you will conclude that the
coin is biased
the coin's not fair and how long it
takes you to admit that the coin is
unfair
is really a function of how confident
you were initially that the coin was
fair
the more confident you are the coin is
fair the longer it takes you to believe
you're actually dealing with an unfair
coin
curses are the same right so a a person
i think should we have no there's no
known mechanism by which you can be
cursed
so my belief that i am cursed is i it's
incredibly unlikely
but eventually the evidence would
could overwhelm it now you know
the red sox not winning the world
foreign years they didn't win the world
series
yeah but it's just because they stunt
right it's not because they were cursed
and then they sold a lot of other
players to the new york yankees and
surprisingly enough the yankees went
ahead and won a load
of like a world series and the red
trucks have been winning before that
yeah
exactly yeah they're quite dominant in
fact so i think
so a curse is such an extraordinarily
unlikely event
i'll let you ask me at the beginning is
the the probability's never zero or one
the probability i'm cursed is you know
microscopic
but eventually i might eventually be
convinced that i that i was cursed i
don't think
you know for a baseball team to be
cursed i believe you would need
more than a lifetime's worth of evidence
the red sox didn't even come close
so do you not get a herd mentality where
all of a sudden
that so many people buy into it that
they cannot
remove that thought from their mind and
therefore it kind of self prophesizes
i don't think so so i've actually i've
looked just like gary you're talking
about a case
where that's how voodoo might work right
right where you're so convinced
you're going to fail that throws off
your game and then you fail
and then you credit the voodoo blame the
the voodoo before that because you have
to fight you have to find a full guy
and therefore it's the the curse or so
so that would mean
performing at very high level athletics
you know that 90 percent of the game is
half mental that's what you're saying
absolutely yeah that's what i tried to
look at
so i played tennis in high school i was
awful and
so you took up astrophysics i'm glad
okay
part of the reason i became convinced
that i was terrible and that made me
worse
but i think when you're talking about
professional athletes
if they are if that if they do that to
themselves
they're not professional athletes they
just can't they're competing against
people who don't if they're susceptible
good one of the things i did when i was
working with the
oregon ducks volleyball team is i got a
bunch of statistics and just
you literally you live in foreign you're
in eugene or i do i live in eugene
oregon
i've worked with the ducks a bunch i was
working with the volleyball team
and they gave me statistics on on every
play
and i said okay let's look at individual
players
who play poorly for the first half of a
match
dude is there any correlation between
they're playing poorly the first half of
a match
and they're playing poorly of the second
half of a match in others have they
gotten in their own heads
and decided they're having a bad night
and the answer was no
there was no such correlation the kids
are as near to machines as the coach can
make them wow
they play badly on one point they shake
it off they play well next and let me
just add
and just to just to to
to blow some smoke in your direction the
you have to know that that was the right
question to ask
right that's a brilliant question and a
simple question that i bet most people
don't think of
because what you're saying is if you if
you're starting to have a bad game
and then it does it affect you mentally
because you already know what they are
physically you know what they're capable
of
and you you ask the right question not
enough people in the world
think about the value of the right
question asked at the right time
so thank you i think that
one of the things that i have learned so
a lot of what i've done is involved
large amounts of data and what you do is
you want to take the data that you get
from whatever source
and you're looking for patterns and the
patterns you're looking for surprises
because when you find a pattern it's a
surprise
might be a curse it might be lack of
curse
but you're looking you learn to look for
patterns and data that's what machine
learning is about that's what statistics
is about it's what data science is about
and when i got all this volleyball data
i just started doing everything i could
think of
i asked a bunch of questions that were
less interesting
but you know this one thank you for
saying was a good question
but it's something that the data was
able to advise me on
and you know so i've done i did the same
thing with basketball
so i i got uh
every basketball play for a year and i
started looking to see is there anything
that predicts whether a player
is going to perform well or poorly in
any particular game
and the answer turned out to be yes and
it was basically the number of minutes
he had played previously and basketball
has a very long memory it turns out that
they're playing a lot early in the
season you carry that burden with you
for the whole rest of the season
but does it help you or hurt you if you
played a lot it hurts
yeah fatigue
yeah as a matter of fact last year uh
before the whole
you know covet so not this past season
that they played but the season before
there was a big argument about certain
players
being so chuck if you want to go before
it's just bc
before coving oh yeah bc
but there was a big controversy about um
allowing players to kind of take a break
during the season
sit out games that weren't as crucial
to allow their bodies to uh
refresh and re-energize in some way
and uh it just became a huge huge thing
and the idea is
damn it i'm paying 80 for a ticket i
want to see shaq play that's it
and that's basically where the
controversy goes and the other
controversy was
i'm paying his salary right the other
controversy is
hey we never did it like this before you
know the guys at the bet
the guys before who came before us are
tougher they're those guys grounded out
for the whole season
what makes you so soft that you got to
take a break but it's
really do you want me to go through my
injury list because
this is another hour now the guys in my
era did exactly that
and we have injuries that last for days
if we start
one end and go to the other yeah we
didn't have guys like matt
who would sit down and now you find an
elite sport we call
asset management i got to pull you out
for two games so as i can have you for
the next two months
because if i play you in those next two
games you're out for those two months
because you're burnt your muscles are in
the good condition
but yeah and there's so much probability
that you're going to receive
one of the things that i found and it
was interesting so it's not just
you know sit steph curry it is
at what point so you know there's three
minutes left in the game
you're up six is that enough that you
should sit him down
and give him six more minutes of rest
today so that he plays better tomorrow
or the next day
and the interesting thing is if you have
all the numbers this becomes
a purely quantitative question you know
if i sit him down for the rest of this
game my chances of winning this game go
down a tiny bit i've probably won it
because we're up six with three minutes
up
but my chances of winning the day after
tomorrow
go up and the game after that they go up
so you end up with this incredibly
quantitative
question and i actually all right okay
so let's come back to that we got to
take a break now but when we come back
we're going to talk about number
crunching in exactly as you're
describing matt and i'm going to ask you
the question
if it's all just a matter of numbers who
needs coaches when
star talk sports edition
we're continues star talk sports edition
we're doing this by the numbers what are
the odds
what does that even mean we got a
mathematician matt
you know matt love having you here just
because i
i think everyone should have their own
personal mathematician
you know speech you just reach for them
when you need one
and that's just i i i love love having
no the guys in the bar who are having
the fight they don't want their own
person they don't want their own
mathematician i want
our own mathematician matt ginsberg
so uh we had we left off with you
describing the decision to sit
a high value player if you're leading
because you don't need them to win the
game
and that could help you win tomorrow's
game or the next game and see these are
decisions
not according to you not left to the
judgment of the coach
but these are with fast computing
and ai thinking about it you can make
these decisions in an instant
all right so presumably that's not just
for
basketball for other sports as well so
um yes you can i mean you can help all
over uh
you help in different ways and
you know so i've i worked with the ducks
football team on whether they should
punt or go for it on fourth down i work
with the volleyball team on when they
should call
timeouts i also
did some you know so i worked with the
volleyball team this was not so
successful
we set up a system where there were two
high definition cameras
and they would watch the volleyball
and the the girls on the team had had uh
smart watches
on their arms under a shooting sleeve
and if the serve was going to be out we
would make the smart watches buzz
and we could tell before the serve got
there that was not successful
um the yellow found out about it they
told us we were bad people and made a
stop
but is it is it illegal or not they
actually
said it was illegal and they didn't know
it should be illegal until they saw that
you were doing it right
well they said it was illegal and we
said why it doesn't break any of the
rules
and they said we don't actually know
which rule it breaks but we are telling
you that it does break the rules and you
have to stop
what they should have said is not that
it breaks rules but that is cheating and
so so uh did you did it calculate based
on a ballistic trajectory
and not an aerodynamic trajectory so um
so you would get it wrong if the ball
has a spin on it one of the things
i did obviously is look to see
whether the ballistic trajectory got the
right answer obviously
of course because well you have to
you've got to test what you're doing you
can't just
get stuff up and then expect though and
the answer was i was able to accurately
predict whether a volleyball server was
going to be in a round
so that was that was just it worked
and um but but cheating you they can't
just say you're just
going to say how does that change how
would that change the game
is it's it's because no you decide
whether you're going to return it or not
servers can be deadly
and if they're out you'd rather not have
to try to return it yeah you would have
oh i see what you're saying so
it happened in that in that such short
period of time that if you're
wearing the watch and it buzzes just do
nothing
yeah that's right wow i would be
pressing i would be buzzing their
watches
pretty much as the ball crossed over
them okay cause that that that's what i
was trying to figure out is
how how much in real time and how yeah
so your reaction time is part of this
too
well i didn't do anything right the
computer was
chuck he programs he doesn't
[Laughter]
so what is the future of coaches if you
can make key decisions such as that
by ai what do you need a coach for so i
think
so it's not so this is not just about
coaches
right so we have ai entities making
more and more decisions for us and i
think the thing that you
you have to realize is
we solve problems totally differently
than machines do
so you know when a person plays chess
they look at a handful of chess
positions when deep blue plays chess
they look at it looks at billions
when we solve problems by pattern
recognition
they solve problems by searching the net
result is that
we are good at one kind of thing and
computers are good at a different
kind of thing so the question about
balancing somebody's
energy how many minutes should they sit
out this game and next game
machines are good at that we're lousy
machines should do
that questions about
motivating the players to practice
harder
to not get drunk before games whatever
it is
the coaches are doing that is very much
a personal interaction
adding value adding experience adding
you know pattern recognition kinds of
things
we're going to keep doing that no wait
wait wait wait no
you no because what happens is i i was
out all night and i was drinking and i
come in and ai tests my blood
and it says your alcohol is two percent
blood i got that joke from a movie
some years ago and i i know a couple of
those players
and so then ai says my data shows that
your performance will be diminished by
this amount
and so they will know exactly how much
your performance would be diminished
but that's not that's not that i'm going
to coach for that when when you can know
the
chemistry of that phenomenon you don't
need a coach
to tell you that your drunk player
shouldn't be playing
you need a coach to convince the player
not to get drunk the night before a game
uh
but didn't tell nameth to get drunk the
night before the super bowl and still
win the super bowl i mean
and and did you know how do you know
that did what was your tanner
i was wearing the i was wearing a
pantyhose so let me ask for those who
are not 100 years old
he did a tv commercial advertising
pantyhose after i think he shaved his
legs did he i don't know
but anyhow anyway let's move on from
that so so
so matt um baseball is famous
for how much statistics plays in the
decisions of coaches
on the level will this shift an entire
infield of players to one side
because of the statistics of how the
batter hits the ball
do other sports lend themselves to this
level of
analysis so um
yes short answer basketball
is right on baseball seals so um
i know a bunch of people involved in the
basketball world and they
are incredibly committed to
exploiting statistical information the
same way the baseball guys do
the other sports are behind so i've been
looking at football and talking to
football people and they know that
they're not taking advantage of
data as much as some of these others and
as you began just a moment ago the
biggest
decision play is do you kick would you
go for fourth
down what then whatever fourth and
short do you kick or do you go for it
and that's
you know everyone that's everyone
debates that the day after
all right if it didn't go the way people
wanted how does just how did how does
data help that
so that is you just do it you just
figure it out
and um and i did work
for the oregon ducks and um i actually
made a deal with them
that i would figure out what they should
do on fourth down and i would get four
season tickets
it worked that's a good deal they said
yes and i told them
every week i would go to them with this
giant book of what to do in every
possible fourth down situation and i
would give it to the coach and i said
the same thing i said look here's the
deal
just stop hunting between the 35 yard
lines you'll be fine
and the oregon ducks stopped punting
between the 35 yard lines
and they they had an amazing year in
part because
not punting between 35 yard lines and
college football was just right
i did then go to him the next year and
ask him if he wanted to do it again
and he said no and i said what
and he said i know not to pump between
the 35-yard lines i'm going to keep my
tickets
and he's and he sent me on my way
so they are starting to make the
decision
this way but not
terribly effectively yet i mean you can
do so much more than
fourth and however fourth and last so
what you're saying is your
your your advice to him was consistent
with his life experience and therefore
it had no value to him
no no no he he when i started working
with him
he never punted he always punted between
35 yard lines
everybody punted so the first time he
followed my advice
he was playing utah was fourth and five
from midfield
and he decided to go for it because i
had been telling him to do this forever
utah was so surprised they had to waste
a timeout
because they had put their punt return
team on the field and he put his normal
offense on
so they had to blow a timeout and then
he got it and he thought well that's
pretty cool
and he did it again and he learned
he just started doing better and if you
watch college football now you will see
that between the 35-yard lines
they go for it a lot okay and this is
starting to trickle into the nfl also
and and and what is the fourth between
the 35 yard lines
is there a qualifier because fourth and
on a penalty between the 35-yard line is
a lot different
fourth and two right between the 35-yard
line yeah so
where's the threshold actual answer is
there is essentially no qualifier
i don't i didn't run it out to fourth
and 47 but
go for it and 15 i think 15 may have
been around the break point but you
really
just go for it and the reason is because
some percentage of plays gets you 15
yards
right sometimes you make it but mostly
hunting
does not help you because college
punters aren't that good they're going
to punch in
and so on so instead of having it at
midfield they have it at their own 20
right and it's not really that much
better it's not that but and also too
um college returns
are a lot advance a lot further because
in the pros if you look at the pros when
they punt
those dudes are right there
and most times that player that player
is
going down okay uh uh uh occasionally
you'll see a breakaway
you might see somebody get 20 or 30
yards on a return which is
far more routine in college than it is
in the pros that's why they're called
special teams chuck because
the other is you should always go for it
on fourth or one
on your own nine go for it on fourth and
one
and the numbers just say it's better
because every now and then you're gonna
get it and then you get a new life
punting from your own nine you're
screwed you were screwed on your nine
you're still screwed because the other
team is going to have the ball
on your own you know and you're 40 and
you're supposed to start yeah
and the coach actually told me he said
stop telling me about this i can't go
for it on fourth
and one from my own nine because if i'm
wrong they're gonna fire me
i don't care if it's right stop talking
me about it
i'm just not interested so i stopped
talking about it but so
so coaches are acting coaches have a lot
more to balance
than simple quantitative decisions right
they have to balance the press and the
fans and people's moods and
stuff that i don't know anything about
because i'm just a numbers guy so are
you telling me the facts don't care
right so when the coach yeah the the
coach
is just riddled with emotions and he's
going to get fired if dot dot dot
what happens when you slide the dossier
across the desk and say
this is factual
how much pushback and and dude is it
never going to happen or do you get like
the embrace the coach eventually gives
you or
is it always it varies enormously right
it's a it's a personal thing i mean
so i've worked with people who have a
huge non-invented ear
syndrome you can tell them any idea and
they will tell you yeah i already
thought of that
it doesn't matter if they have or not
yeah okay
dealing with football coaches a football
coach may say if i go for it on my own
nine i'm fourth and one and i'm wrong i
get fired and he's right
yeah cause it's his job to know what
gets him fired
then you can't you know he said stop
trying to talk to me about it yeah but
in baseball if you make a statistical
decision
you're not going to get fired because
everyone knows the power of those
statistics
and then in the long run you're going to
win and and you have 162 freaking games
because it's a marathon not a sprint now
maybe football each game has
is a little more critical let me how
about what about the hail mary pass
is that is that a statistical thing
i don't know i i actually um just looked
at this and i can tell you that it looks
like
you it works about two percent of the
time
but it's not um
but it's riskless right because yeah you
are you have the ball at midfield
there's six seconds left in the game
you're down by
four if you don't throw a hail mary pass
you are guaranteed to lose
lose if you do throw a hail mary pass
you get two percent chance of winning
i'll take two percent over zero percent
any day
it's not the kind of decision what
people get upset with
is you go for it on fourth and one and
statistically it's right
but it was wrong spectacularly today
okay okay so the the the alternative to
hail mary pass is a quarterback run
with 12 consecutive laterals
right that's that's the alternative to
that and
have you thought much about that that's
that's a lot of ball handling which
always
carries a risk i no so you have to
understand i can't think about that
because i don't think about football i
think about numbers
and there no there is no data on people
trying this
multiple lateral play yes it would be
you could say
what fraction of laterals are fumbled
right because it's another ball handle
right and and so there's got to be some
access into that well the problem is
that every lateral has to be backwards
yeah right so uh
eventually you may run out of field but
the real problem is you're not moving
the ball forward as you're as you're
lateraling
occasionally you do see somebody you
know there's a kickoff return at the end
of a game and people start lateraling
around it never works i've never seen it
work i have seen hail mary's
yeah right and then there's also the
trick play
like which is a variation of a lateral
where and it normally only happens on
kickoffs
where the uh returner
will receive the ball and then
you because you can forward pass as long
as the
ball is not going forward so
he throws the ball across the field to
another player
which looks like a forward pass but
because it's going uh
in in back it's going backwards it's
considered a lateral
and then that player is free from
construction he's wide open and he's got
a big long field level and if he's
fast enough he can actually avoid being
tackled
so yeah we gotta take a quick break we
gotta take a quick break when we come
back
i uh matt i wanna get into sort of what
made you who you are if i can spend a
couple of minutes
doing that and still connected to the
theme what what mad
scientist puts you together matt
what basement were you invented all
right uh we'll take a quick break
this is star talk sports edition by the
numbers
when we return we're back
star talk sports edition what are the
odds and we got mathematician matthew
gettysburg
so so matt we you briefly mentioned that
and you just said off the cuff oh hail
mary passes work two percent of the time
and you know i don't i don't have to
run numbers to know that it doesn't
happen often but when you say two
percent
you probably mean exactly two percent so
how did you how do you actually get that
number
so for that number which um
your team actually asked me about i
looked at all the football data i have
so i have every nfl play since 1999
and the question is which are the hail
mary's so i said okay you got to be
down more than a field goal but a
touchdown can tie it so you got to be
down four to eight points
you have to be at least 30 yards away
from the end zone so you have at least
30 yards to go
it has to be the end of the game which i
defined as either less than 20 seconds
left to play or less than a minute left
to play and it's fourth down so you're
desperate
and i looked at all the plays that were
like that and how many of them were
actually recorded as being a deep
pass which is part of the data i have
there were 187 plays in desperate
situations like that
that were recorded as deep passes and of
those hundred and eighty seven plays
four were touchdowns so i can then tell
you two percent
two point one percent of hail mary's
work wow
wow but as you say two point one percent
over nothing
yeah it's two percent over over zero
percent right yeah if you don't do it
you you know you're not that's okay so
in this third segment
which we've we're still trying to find a
good name for it but until we do we're
just calling it shoot the so
so what um i got a question for you man
um if i remember correctly was it
deep blue yes or whichever
ibm computer beat the world's best go
champion
okay that was a google computer google
sorry
google it was yeah that's right google
what and what was the name of that
computer
i think it was alphago as i think what
they call it okay alphago
and uh i remember chatting with some
google people and apparently you can do
one of two things
if you have machine learning deep
machine learning ai
you can say all right let's study every
single game ever played which is you can
do with chess because every
important game is recorded right and
have it learn
moves that worked and didn't work and it
could have the sum
of all human knowledge and thereby beat
practically any human who plays it so we
can
we that makes sense but then in the
follow-on
google program it didn't do that it said
what is the goal of the game oh it's to
de-mark
territories and to prove is that the
goal well let me play myself
and do what i think i need to do
to win and let me play a billion games
against myself doing that
that program beat the previous
program that had beaten all previous go
players
and then it exploded yeah
and then tear in the space time
continuum opened up
so my question is matt at what point are
you going to say
my best data are all of the games ever
played
rather than my best data are the games
that could be played
that i can think up and have never been
played
and thereby i'm gonna make a giant leap
for this sport
like the first person to bunt that must
have been a crazy like what is that
oh something had to invent that right a
person remember
uh it was fosbury it was a fosberg
fosberry flop
1968 olympics mexico city somebody does
something brand new
just to be clear because i i've noticed
that people know that that's a better
way to jump over the bar but i they
don't always know why but
give me like 30 seconds to explain that
so if you
watch old high jumpers um they would go
forward over the bar
and you can only really bend
at your waist your legs can't
bend in the opposite direction than they
do
so your legs have to clear the bar
straight
whereas if you go backwards over the bar
your back
can curl you can curl backwards at your
waist and your legs can dangle
so you can make a a hemi circle a
semi-circle
and curl yourself around the bar taking
your center of mass below the bar
even though your body goes above the bar
so you can jump higher than ever before
by actually jumping lower than ever
before
in a world record um setting jump
so because when you're curling your
center mass is no longer in your body
is outside of your body and you didn't
actually have to jump as high so you
could say that was cheating
but they they left it in and now
everybody jumps that way
so i just have to slip that in because i
i've noticed that not everyone knows
that even some athletes so continue that
sorry i interrupted
so what what i do
what people working machine learning
generally do
is they and i said this before you look
for patterns and data
the more data you have the more likely
it is
the patterns you detect are real the
more likely the easier it becomes to
find the pattern so you want as much
data as you possibly can have
and there obviously is a
is a choice you either can use naturally
occurring data
data from chess games or you can use
synthetic data you generate it by
playing yourself for example
and there's a trade-off the naturally
occurring data is at some level
gonna be better it's hard to imagine
computer simulations of football games
being
of much value for example but you do
have the opportunity to generate more
data
by by playing yourself by using other
computers
at this point computers are way better
at chess than we are so the way you
the data you want you want to look at
the data from stockfish which is the
best
non-ai non-machine learning based
program
so i guess it's all ai from my
perspective
you just want to do what works i don't
care where the data comes from
as long as what i learned from it is
actually valid
so yeah but it's more fun if your
program invents a new football play
that no one thought of because it
because it
didn't want to base itself on games that
were played before
and wow i want to see innovation because
that's you know
and i guess that's what trick plays are
but yes
but but and and is that true creativity
and is that what we're doing as human
beings looking around and seeing
uh looking for misdirection looking
for ways to make your opponent
uh think something that's not happening
uh
that's how we come up with new plays and
that is also a part of pattern
recognition
as a matter of fact in football they
call it disguising a defense and all
that kind of stuff
so yeah and not only that the very final
play
in the movie major league was basically
a trick play
and that's baseball right what happened
is the batter points to the outfield
okay and so so that's you know
that's guy he's showing some gonads
there right points like he's gonna hit
and then instead he turns around and
bunts and so
the third baseman has to come running in
because they were playing in deep
there was a whole construct there let me
let me give you
let me actually try and answer this
[Music]
okay i would rather just argue at you
yes i know
i'm gonna actually ask you the question
back when i worked for the ducks
i actually did invent a new play and
um i describe the play as an
optional self-safety so there are
situations in football where you
actually want to score a safety on
yourself
and then take the kick off from the 20
and so forth and so on
and i created a another kind of play
which was you go back for a pass throw
pass
if your pass is basically guaranteed
because the guy is
just wide open throw the pass
otherwise step out the back of the end
zone and do a safety on yourself
new play nobody had ever thought of
before
so possibility one is that the ducks win
a crucial game
because i gave them this new play
possibility two is the ducks win a
crucial game
because i got him to stop punting
between the 35-yard lines
for me possibility two is just as much
fun that's the question you originally
asked is just as much fun as possibility
one because i did it
i know i did it i don't have to go and
pick up a girl in a bar
by telling her i invented this the
passing cell safety
by the way that wouldn't work
if you've said that you've tried it no
no
it works in the nerd bar but otherwise
i know when i watch a football game when
i watch a college football game and i
see somebody punt not between the
35-yard lines
i smile from ear because i did that
it's just as good as if i invented this
play that people run from time to time
it's just as much
fun what i did was just as impactful
and whether it was something that that
sort of looks really splashy like
pointing to the outfield and then
bunting or whether it's something that's
just grinding it out by doing the
numbers and figuring out what to do on
fourth down
impact is impact winning is winning all
right so then why don't
why don't batters who are statistically
predicted to hit
80 of their line drives to the left side
of the infield
why don't they just punch one to the
right side
and s or save that for when they really
need it and
or is it an ego that they're fighting
yeah i'll get through them even though
they're putting their best stuff on me
you have to ask a baseball player um i
have played a bit
and your natural swing is going to go a
particular way and
messing with it is at your own peril i
got you
right let's look at football and
basketball because they are not as
statistically driven as baseball
is there one thing in each sport
barring the fourth in one situation that
you know you hear announcers talking
about is there one thing in each sport
that
you would say this is what they're all
not
doing that if they did they would find
a greater success so basketball
basketball really is very statistical
these days and i don't understand
basketball nearly as well as i
understand the other games so i'm going
to leave basketball out of it
football yes so there is one incredibly
easy thing
that people don't do in football and
they're crazy
and that is um you score a touchdown
and you have to decide whether to kick
the extra point or go for two
it turns out that your expected number
of points scored is pretty much the same
you're about 50 50 to make it if you go
for two
so all you're doing when you decide to
go for two instead of taking the extra
point is you're adding
sort of noise the sq you're adding
uncertainty
and that means and this is incredible
but in because you said something that i
don't know is if it's completely clear
to others so when he says your expected
results are the same
what he's saying is if there's a 50
chance you're gonna score two points
then half the time you score it the
other half you don't on average you
scored one extra point
which is the same as the guaranteed one
extra point um
that was the traditional add-on so i
think i said that correctly
right matt okay yes continue yes so you
can either have
a very straightforward one point you
know it's gonna be one it's not gonna be
zero it's not gonna be two it's just
gonna be one
or you can have like a noisy one point
where it's half the time it's there and
half the time it's two
so the question you should be asking is
do i want noise
in the football score and the answer is
if you're playing a team that's better
than you
you do because the way you're gonna win
this game
is by making is by getting a little bit
lucky
and you want to give the gods of luck as
much chance as possible to help you
you want to increase what's called the
standard deviation in the score you want
to make it
that you can't move the average but you
can make it noisier and you want to
climb out to the
wings of that distribution where you
could have actually a chance of winning
that game
as the underdog yes so every underdog in
football that pours a touchdown should
go for two
and it's obvious and it's simple and i
have no idea why they don't do it
they don't think apparently it's not
obvious that people don't have a phd in
mathematics
with the three that they earn from a
nobel prize-winning brilliant physicist
we got to actually land this plane uh
but to take us out
uh matt just tell me what what was
factor man what what is that book
you wrote a book in 2018 what is that i
did it is
um i have spent a lot of my professional
career working on a particular technical
problem
and if you solve it you can solve all
the other problems literally
and it's a book about a guy who does
and uh so it's a novel
it's enough oh cool cool it's a thriller
it's a thriller
a mathematical thriller two words you've
never seen in the same sentence
i've often talked to my friends about
you know if you solve this problem it is
actually a race between whether you take
over the world but the government kills
you and
and this guy who lost his problem is in
this race he knows he's in this race
i'm watching that when it comes out on
netflix because they'll surely buy the
story
anyway that's what factor man is about
oh excellent excellent i'll look for
that and
uh and greatest name ever for computer
program dr
phil with the f-i-l-l tell me about that
dr phil is uh i don't remember who
suggested the name i actually
it's a program that solves crossword
puzzles and
uh neil you and i have both created
crossword puzzles
i've co-created the courser puzzle for
the next i am
i am awful at crossword puzzles when i
have a puzzle in the new york times it
takes about a year from the time you
submit it till the time it comes out i
can't do my own puzzles when they're
finally published
so i wrote this program that's really
good at solving crossroad puzzles it's
sort of my revenge on all the people who
are so so much better than i am
but i needed a name and uh i asked the
community of crossroad puzzle
constructors for a name and one guy
suggested deep clue
nice good one that was good and somebody
else suggested dr phil which i thought
was a tiny bit better so
that's how very cool so so in other
words never
wrong a geek because whatever they're
not good at they'll create a robot that
is
yes
yeah matt matt we gotta we gotta call it
quits there but thank you for being on
star talking sports is a delight to hear
how you've contributed
to this and this is surely not the end
of that story
there's much more um infusion that math
will
have not only in sports but the rest of
our lives and i
i think overall the more the better and
we look forward to this so
thanks for being on star talk chuck gary
always a pleasure always thank you
always a pleasure we're here i'm neil
degrass tyson
your personal astrophysicist as always
getting
to keep looking up
you